see thursday i'm pete here
and i'm happy to have you during the
summer months of august
you know that we've been interviewing
top data engineers and data scientists
the leaders of open source data projects
over the past few weeks and today i'm
excited to have robert nishihara here
who's
the co-author of ray and the co-founder
of a new company
called any scale so robert welcome
thank you thank you nice to have you
here virtually i see you're in san
francisco
i'm obviously in jackson hole um but
you know with the wonders of zoom we're
able to uh be here
and i'm not even sure if our socks were
matching but i think maybe that's the
sign of the new era yeah that sounds
right
so um robert i've heard a lot about ray
um we actually had julia gonzalez uh
speak to us
maybe a year and a half ago or so on
some of the research that was coming out
of the rise lab
at berkeley and it's been awesome to see
that ray
um is being supported by now commercial
entity that you've started
um we won't talk too much about that
unless there's there's
aspects that you want to bring up but um
specifically about ray the open source
project i'm really curious to hear
the background there um how you got
dragged into it
um i know that you're one of these
unique types who
had a lot of internships had a lot of
amazing tech companies while you were
studying for your phd so you've had a
interesting academic and commercial or
uh or a corporate past but um tell us a
little bit
about that and how you got how you got
into the ray project for sure
um yeah so when i started the phd i was
focused
on machine learning and machine learning
theory and actually
you know trying to design better
algorithms for optimization and things
like that
and you know one of the challenges that
we ran into over and over you have
all these machine learning researchers
who want to focus on
machine learning algorithms and
applications but actually spend
quite a bit of their time doing pretty
low level
engineering to scale things up or or
speed things up and so
in order to test out your new machine
learning algorithm you may end up
building quite a lot of infrastructure
scaffolding and and that's uh something
we found ourselves doing
repeatedly um and so we thought there
had to be a better way
so you know we began with a few of us
building this open source project and
really trying to build something useful
and
and you know since then rey has come a
long way we now have
over 300 contributors and coming from
around 100 different companies
and you know the high level trend that
rey is trying to solve the high you know
high level trend that we're
um you know trying to address is just
that distributed computing is
is really becoming the norm that more
and more applications especially
applications involving machine learning
in some shape or form
need to run on clusters and it's very
difficult to do that
you know there's not a lot of great ways
to scale up your
your python applications or your machine
learning applications especially
and we can talk more about about that
but um
and you know so we're trying to make it
really easy trying to make distributed
computing
as easy as programming on your laptop
ideally
yeah that that makes sense um it's
interesting that you
you talk about machine learning but you
also talk about
generically about distributed computing
and this is one of the things that
you'd like to emphasize about the ray
project where in the beginning i thought
it was mostly for machine learning
applications only but i know that
it's broader than that can you tell us a
little bit more about that
yeah that's that's a good point i think
to do machine learning
well or to to really support machine
learning well
you actually need a pretty general
framework because machine learning is
not
something you i mean not always
something you do in isolation where you
just train a neural network or you just
deploy your your machine learning model
in production but rather
there's often it's often integrated into
more complex applications where you
might have
you know data streaming and you're
processing the data in a streaming
fashion
then you're taking those features that
you're extracting and you know
and incrementally training new models
and then you're taking those models and
and deploying them in production and
you know serving recommendations to
users or things like that and you
there are so many different moving parts
machine learning is being
integrated into so many different kinds
of applications that's when order
you know in order to support machine
learning applications well
you end up needing to be able to handle
you know data you need to handle
uh you know serving you need to handle
streaming all these all these different
kinds of things and so
you know ray is um you know the the eco
system where like there are two layers
to ray
there's the core runtime which if you
look at the api
it's very it's very um it's fairly low
level and it's very general purpose so
um it's basically the ability to take
python functions and python classes
and scale those up to run those in the
cluster setting and that's
uh so the api consists of tasks and
actors and we can talk more about that
um so that has nothing to do with
machine learning but then with those
primitives
we're building an ecosystem of scale you
know libraries on top for scalable
machine learning
and those libraries um are are primarily
targeting scalable machine learning and
that includes things like
training hyper parameter search
reinforcement learning
serving and so on and they're actually a
number of interesting really cool third
party libraries that people are building
um that uh that expand that ecosystem
got it um you mentioned
already like scaling up python and so
um i thought that we could um give you a
chance to
to clarify and contrast ask in a in a
larger ecosystem
um i'm i'm sorry ray in a in a larger
ecosystem
um often comes up and so i'm curious
as to how you compare and contrast the
two
yeah that's a great question and you
know
this challenge of of of doing
distributed python or scaling up python
is just
it's a pain point for a lot of people
and there are a lot of really great
projects that are
trying to address that problem and when
i actually
when i was actually in undergrad and
first starting out in research and had
ran into this problem
this was a while back i was using um
ipython
parallel which is a uh you know an
earlier instantiation of this and
and of course was was really magical to
use at the time
um before i talk about you know the
differences between
desk and ray there's actually been a
really interesting uh
contribution that came across in the
past week or so
where someone in the community developed
a thin layer that lets you 200 or 300
lines of
code that lets you run um desk
applications on top of ray cluster so
essentially
um importing the das api to
uh to write so you can actually use the
das and ray apis
uh in that you know they can
interoperate within the same application
pretty seamlessly and that's
that's that's um pretty impressive there
was
um you know the fact that you can i mean
the fact that the author could do this
in 200 or 300 lines of code suggests you
know is that's
only because desk has some really well
designed abstractions um
and this lets users take their you know
data frame library
or array library and um
and run that on the array cluster so
that's that's sort of an interesting
um uh pretty pretty cool thing that i
came across recently
um now so what's the difference between
ray and ask
there's some pretty big i would say
there are obviously a lot of
architectural differences
but the one that what i would focus on
is the api differences
so i mentioned ray has tasks and actors
so it lets you take python functions and
python classes
and really uh you know run those in the
cloud in the distributed setting
the desk um so
the i would say that the majority of ray
applications are really using
ray actors and at its core rays um
you know the actor focus is a is a big
part of ray
you know how how ray works and so and we
you know that's important for us because
we just wouldn't be able to support the
kinds of applications that we
uh you know are trying to support with
in with you know training machine
learning models or
serving models in production or um or
doing reinforcement learning
these kinds of things we wouldn't be
able to support them as easily without
the actor abstraction and um
and so that's a huge focus for ray
that's not uh and
whereas the desk api the lower level
desk api is much more similar to
the ray task api for scaling up python
functions
so i think for users that's probably a
pretty important difference
and there are you know there are other
smaller differences or
maybe not smaller but ray is starting to
support other languages like java and
c plus plus and things like that got it
um and a core component of ray is that
it allows for stateful
processing that's right that's why
that's
so important sorry why is that important
yeah um you know for a lot of
a lot of uh well
when you're developing if you forget
about the distributed setting and you're
just developing applications
on your laptop using python scripts it's
very natural to use not just
python functions but also to use python
classes and that's because
the logic that you're trying the
application logic you're trying to
develop
there's often state and that state needs
to be
encapsulated in classes and that's a
natural way to
develop the applications and the same is
true in the distributed setting the same
kinds of applications
when you scale them up they often still
have state that could be the state of a
neural network which is you know
changing over time
like the weights of the neural network
that could be the state of some
uh you know encapsulation of the state
of the real world or that you're
you know interacting with um and you
know there's sometimes
it's not that it's you can't do it
without
um state it's just that the natural way
to
uh write these applications um is with
classes got it
so i just want to mention to the
audience that um we'll be taking
questions for robert
in the chat window so if you have
questions that you want to
interject into the conversation we're
happy to to take those at any time so
feel free to sound off
um so so robert on that note obviously
both
spark and ray come from research
at berkeley um ray supports
state which is a key notion and sort of
a key
idea behind the platform um what are
some of the other design principles
that you followed like what what did you
optimize for when you were thinking
about constructing rey and walk us
through that process if you don't mind
yeah so the design principles that we
care about for rey
are one um simplicity so
and ease of use and when i say um
you know and the reason for this is that
if you
you know distributed computing is is is
quite complex it's quite hard
right it's conceptually there's a lot a
lot going on
and you know our goal is to enable
people
who know python uh to develop their
applications and scale their
applications
without needing to be experts in
distributed computing right so we
really care about having a simple
intuitive api
because if you don't have that then you
know you can already do distributed
computing just by using
much lower level tools like tcp sockets
and
and and so on um but that doesn't uh
that that's you know of course then you
have to build a ton on top
so really and making us you know simple
intuitive api
is important for just allowing a much
bigger audience to
easily take advantage of distributed
computing so
simplicity and you know ease of use is
the first thing
the second thing is about generality so
we want to have a few like i mentioned
simple apis
um that that are quite powerful and and
let you uh build a lot of things on top
so
you know if you look at a uh
and this is the advantage of having a
lower level api so
if we provided a higher level api like
you can imagine
a system like tensorflow the api is more
around neural networks right and so if
you're
developing um applications that do you
know train neural networks that's the
perfect api to have
but if you are doing if you're going to
do data processing or stream processing
or something it's
you know it's not the right api and with
ray if you have a we have a fairly low
level apis
functions and classes so on top of that
[Music]
you can you know they're quite general
so you can build
uh you know a huge variety of different
applications on top
in the same way that you on your laptop
you can build a ton of applications
using
functions and classes so that we try to
have a very
flexible general api in addition to the
simplicity
and then the third one is about
performance like it really needs to be
fast
because if well
performance is a you know a key enabler
for generality right if it's not
uh if it's not fast enough then there
are going to be a ton of
applications that you can't support
because those applications require
uh that level of performance and
actually
this is one of the challenges with
trying to design a very general purpose
distributed system you know if you
support a variety of different
applications then you
inherit the performance requirements of
all those different applications right
so
you know some apple you know some
category of applications requires
really low latency and some other
applications you know require really
high
throughput or tasks or something like
that then you know your system
has to support both of those things got
it
so yeah so simplicity and the ease of
use
you know flexibility uh and performance
awesome and so so what about the
architecture talk to us a little bit
about the basic architecture
and and what we should expect there yeah
so the architecture
you know that's a great the great
question it's actually evolved quite a
bit
over well we've it's gone through a
number of iterations and one thing we've
done with ray
is we've rewritten it from scratch um
three or four times there was actually
in
you know with with almost almost
completely new
code bases um there
and each time you know it's it's it's
gotten a lot better there was an
original um prototype array the first
prototype was built in rust
next iteration was using c plus and
then we actually had a for quite a while
we
had a clean slate implementation in in c
um and more recently it's
um then we uh we you know we switched
back to c plus plus using building on
top of
uh grpc primarily and um
and then and then you know that and that
architecture has lasted for a while and
we were also
but well that language choices lasted
for a while
um but even within you know that choice
we
we sort of changed a lot of the the
concepts so
if you read the original rey paper from
i think 2018
it's some of the concepts have have
changed
um but to say a little bit about how the
architecture works
it's designed to avoid um centralized
bottlenecks
so whenever there are components like
schedulers you know that
that could be that are sort of a
logically centralized concept
we uh you know we replicate those or
shard those
to avoid them actually becoming
bottlenecks
um and scheduling is a good example so
we actually run
one uh scheduler on each machine in the
ray cluster
and then uh when
you know when workers on on a given
machine
are have tasks that they they want to
submit or want to run
they first talk to the scheduler on that
machine and then
that scheduler might redirect them to
another scheduler but um
but that's one of the uh uh
the key things for scalability um
you know ray is also really designed
with performance and fault tolerance in
mind so
on the performance side one optimization
i'll mention is the ray object store
which actually
um this is this lets
different worker processes on the same
machine use shared memory to
easily access the same data or the same
objects without needing to create their
own copies without needing to
duplicate the memory and and do
expensive serialization and
deserialization
so the you know user take like heavily
using
leveraging shared memory is um
you know really a pretty important
performance optimization for a lot of
uh for ray and a lot of machine learning
applications heavily
use numerical data and um
and so that's that comes up a lot and
then
yeah those are those are some of the
things i would highlight i guess with
with fault tolerance you know it's
designed
in a way where you can imagine any
process or any machine
failing at any time and that's and
that's something we want
to um you know things to continue
working
without uh without any hiccups
got it um and so
i i know that you were inspired by some
other frameworks and systems
um when you were thinking through how
you wanted to design
ray talk to us about some of those and
where your inspiration came from
well there there are a ton of different
um you know i would say the the biggest
one there there is
is is um you know we were in the ryze
lab right in the amp lab
and surrounded by experts
who you know who had people who had
built spark and also you know people
built mesos and a number of other uh
really successful projects
and that was immensely
valuable right because there are all
these experts in you know we were
coming from more of a machine learning
background doing um
we were familiar with the machine
learning applications that we wanted to
run
but at the time we weren't you know we
hadn't didn't have as much experience
with
distributed systems so having
uh being able to learn from all those
that experience uh
you know was was critical to being able
to um
you know it was really the perfect
environment this combination of people
in machine learning and
and systems to uh to be able to create
this kind of project
yeah that's great um what a benefit to
to being surrounded by
some great visionaries and and engineers
in the space
i'm sure that was a real pleasure to
work with some of those and i know
you've brought some of those
on as advisors and co-founders
to any scale as well so congrats on that
yeah it is it is uh it has been really
fantastic
so we have a question from rick lammers
hey rick
um rick rick has a couple questions
one is what's the recommended way to get
starting with streaming data processing
in ray
is there a specific approach that works
best currently
because of integrations or adapters that
already exist
um so the best way is probably to look
at
on the ray in the ray repository the
github repository there's a
streaming directory and that has some uh
some examples uh for how to you know how
to do streaming on top of ray
it's it's it's a bit you know it's it's
still
like experimental it hasn't this
particular library that's being
developed
um it's it's being used in production by
some companies but
it's uh you know there's still some
rough edges so that's
that's sort of the status there but i
think that's the best way to
to get started okay great um and since i
want to transition
into use cases anyway he also has
another question
you've had some incredible success in
applying your framework to reinforcement
learning will
rl be the most important application
area going forward
um for ray
so i think you know
reinforcement learning was a natural
starting point
because it's an example of something
that's really
hard to do with existing systems like if
you want to do reinforcement learning on
top of
spark or even tensorflow or other
systems it's
it it's not really you know so easy to
do that
and you actually if you look at
companies doing
uh large-scale reinforcement learning
like open ai with their dota project or
you know deepmind with alphago and so on
they're typically building
brand new distributed systems to run
these applications
and so this is you know we felt that
reinforcement learning really highlights
uh the need for a more general purpose
distributed system
and and that was something we could
showcase you know that you could do well
with ray
um but from the start and
if you look at the api for ray it's
something that
you know we intend this to be very
general we really think we want to make
it easy to scale up python applications
to
to do distributed python and
so so that will be so you know
reinforcement learning is still a focus
for us but it's not
but it's one of many different things
we're trying to support well
got you so so the average python
engineer is a target
user of ray is that what i'm hearing
from you
that's right yeah so you know really you
can imagine someone
they they've developed they weren't even
thinking about distributed computing
right they wrote their python
application
um uh maybe as a hobby maybe at their
company
and they got the logic you know to do
what they wanted
but now it's it's too slow or they need
to you know they want to scale it up
they need it to go faster and you know
they don't want to rewrite their
application from scratch and
and they and they don't want to think a
lot about um
setting up infrastructure or building uh
you know infrastructure for handling
failures or
or you know uh fault tolerance or these
kinds of things
they really just want to focus on their
application
logic and and be able to not change the
application logic much but
maybe um you know and so we're trying to
let them make a few changes in port ray
and
and so on uh to to be able to take
advantage of all the
uh you know to do distributed computing
great um so what are
what are some other use cases um for ray
like besides the
the pinnacle reinforcement learning um
example that you gave and that you
started with
um what are some other practical
use cases that you're seeing from the
community now are there any
commonalities or are folks
um using it for one thing more than
another or how do you sort of size up
how the community is using rate
currently i think a lot of the the
coolest applications are the ones that
are
integrating um different kinds of
computational patterns together and
that are things that to do without ray
you would actually need to use multiple
different distributed systems
so one example i alluded to earlier
is so one company has been building
online
essentially like an online learning
recommendation system where they have
they have a data streaming in from users
and they're
and they're processing this data in a
streaming fashion to extract
features then they're taking those
features and training
uh they're incrementally updating
recommendation models
and then they're serving they're
deploying those models and serving
recommendations
back to the users which then feeds back
into the data collection
um it's actually really really
impressive the
turnaround time for um
a data point coming in to a
recommendation going out
from a model that was trained using that
data is around five minutes
uh which is is much faster than you know
these
the way these applications are typically
architected
um and so before they were you know
before this whole thing is built on top
of ray
before before you know using ray the way
they did this was they had to actually
stitch together three different
distributed systems they had one for
stream processing one for training and
one for serving
and so um and of course you know that's
on the more complex
end of the spectrum in terms of what
people are using ray for but
um you know there are a lot of things
uh that that fall into that kind of
category
oh that's interesting that um you cite a
model serving
use case um what's the what's the
general team overhead
um required to be able to get up and
running on ray like what size of project
is too small for someone to to dive in
you know um you you can have uh
a single you can it can be a single
person um
you don't need you know um a large team
to to use ray you can it can start out
with one person
who you know came across it on the came
across the documentation
installed it on their laptop just you
know with pip install ray and then
started playing around with it too just
to try it out on their laptop
and and the great thing there you know
um
and we do have some companies where you
know there's essentially
uh it was just one person started using
it and then and
and that was successful with it and then
and then you know expanded from there
um the
um i forgot what i was gonna say
um the
let's see um yeah so
you know there's some good examples of
companies like that um
and you know and that that's one of the
things that people really
say that they love about rey is the fact
that um
they often don't need to think about it
that much at all right they
start by developing their applications
they get their application in logic
to do what they they wanted to do
without even thinking about scale that
much
and then you know and then after the
fact go in and
and and try to scale it up and it's
typically
you know without they don't have to be
architected they're often able to
make fairly unintrusive changes you know
not always but in a lot of cases
and and and that's something that's you
know that that really simplifies the
workflow because you can just start with
your application logic on your laptop
then like
import ray and and try to parallelize it
across multiple cores on your laptop
and then once you've got that working
then the same code should run on
you know on a cluster and um what sort
of community support
resources are there currently i know you
mentioned at the beginning of the
conversation that
there are hundreds of companies and
contributors
um sort of all involved in the ray
ecosystem um
what's the best place for people to get
support from that community
you know so they're a bunch of different
ways but um what we've found has worked
quite well is actually slack so we have
a slack that's open you know that anyone
can join
and they're different uh it's a great
way to have
to you know people ask questions about
bugs they're running into
they post uh errors they also they ask
questions about
you know how to do certain things or or
um
we discuss uh we collaborate with
different contributors there we discuss
plans about
um you know uh
you know upcoming features and things
like that
got it so that's that's been a really
great way to
interact with the rey community i mean
it's it's um
i i wish we had started that earlier
well i know you've also been super
active in
doing a live stream events and digital
events
this year um so that's been great
great to see um and i i noticed a lot of
those recorded and are available
on your website from community talks
that you've been doing i think monthly
on raise all right
that's right so there have been talks
about we've been doing online
um essentially like mini
conferences or meetups and and as well
as tutorials where we're teaching people
how to
you know use well there will be one
focused on like how to do hyper
parameter tuning on ray or how to do
um you know machine learning operations
on ray
or you know and then there'll be talks
about from
different companies that are are doing
that
and um back to sort of the
the system um and the way
ray works and fits in the ecosystem like
are there specific tools that you see
or systems that you see ray replacing
i mean we talked a lot about comparison
and contrast with some of the other
tools right now but
um is there any like particular area
where an engineer who uses axe you think
will get a big improvement from using
ray or
is that too specific of a question so no
that's fine i mean there
are a couple different answers to that
so one is
um i think the alternative to ray is
often
building your own distributed system or
building your own uh
and you might use tools like grpc um
and um and so
you know really for people who like for
example
all these these companies are people
building um
who were building like you know
distributed systems to do reinforcement
learning
instead of of having to build their own
distributed system we'd like to let
these people
really just focus on the application
logic and and not have to worry
about the the systems part so that's
that's the goal there
um yeah that's i would say that's the
main thing
and so when you think about the roadmap
of ray
like what are you particularly excited
about that's coming up
yeah so one um
one uh conceptual thing that we are
really focused
on is the idea of i'm sure you're
familiar with serverless computing
and here i don't mean specifically uh
aws lambdas i mean the
idea of letting people focus on their
application logic
and not really not have to worry about
how the cluster scales up or scales down
or how how many servers there are or
what runs on which machines
um really just letting the user think
about the application and not
um and not have to be aware of all the
different servers or what that
configuration you know instance types
what that looks like um
and it just you know automatically uh
chooses the right instance types scales
up and down as appropriate
and and runs your application and you
know and so
making that work really seamlessly is
something that
you know we're really excited about
um and i know you're listening to the
community for
feedback and trying to figure out like
what to build
next um like what's come out of the
community
so far what are some other um exciting
things that you've seen built
on top array yeah so i mean there are
small things as well as
big things i think um you know one thing
that we started doing
more more recently which we should have
should have done ages ago but as uh
is just really good support for typing
in python um
and that's that's important for a number
of reasons it you know lets you
um you know obviously type check your
applications but also it lets you
um you know it gives better support for
like uh autocomplete and ides and things
like that
um so that's you know one example um
there's one really exciting thing we've
started to see a number of different
um third-party you know libraries
choosing ray to
to scale up those libraries and um
and you know i mentioned uh
contributions like
being able to run desk data frames on
top of ray or being able to
um you know starting to write they're a
bunch of natural language processing
libraries that you can now start to
um that are you can scale up with ray
so really trying to grow the ecosystem
around ray that's been an important
um thing that people are interested in
um those are those are the ones that
come to mind
okay great yeah um
i know that you have for the community
um keeping the community veined i know
that you have
a ray summit coming up in september
that's exciting tell us about that
yeah so you know this is something we
want to provide an opportunity
for um more people in the in the
community to
to really highlight their uh to really
see
interesting industry use cases and to
and to really highlight some of these
use cases so
there will be talks from a bunch of
different companies um
showcasing how they're using ray in
production or how they're using
ray to solve their problems also a
number of um
other uh libraries and and eco
in the ecosystem that are being scaled
up using ray
um and there will be a number of you
know uh
keynote speakers from who are are uh
high profile people in the python
community or machine learning community
and and uh you know have a lot of
interesting things to say about about
these topics
and so that's something we're super
excited about it's the best place to
learn about
how ray is being used in industry um
and yeah it's a free conference um
and that's just so that's something
we're really excited about that's really
exciting well we'll make sure to include
the link
um in the chat and we'll also mention
that to our community
um as well so that's uh yeah congrats on
launching that and that'll be exciting
to see develop
over the years thank you
um we have another question from andrew
hey andrew
andrew's asking what serverless
abstractions
are you evaluating and or using
yeah so when i say serverless um the
this it's actually um the way you use
ray wouldn't change too much so the api
like the ray
the way you develop applications with
ray would still be the same api you're
still
taking your python functions and python
classes uh and
and you know developing your application
using ray tasks and actors
so it's the same way for writing these
ray applications it's just that
now when you um when you
you know it will provide a way to run
that say on on aws or wherever
that's um that automatically chooses the
right instance types that
scales the cluster up and down
appropriately that um
you know that so that let you know so
you don't have to really
make all these choices to configure the
cluster and figure out the right
um uh to wait a sec the way to set that
up or the right way to
you know size the cluster
got it it's not it's not changing the
programming model so
we're not you know aws lambdas has a
pretty
restrictive programming model and so
it's not uh it wouldn't be coercing
things into that form
okay um so
robert this is a little bit of a change
of direction but i know we have lots of
engineer
founders in our community um and you and
i are both
engineers who have started companies i'm
just curious like what's the most
surprising thing that you've learned
being an engineer founder
of something new um
that's a great question i think
you know one thing that maybe it
shouldn't
shouldn't be surprising but um
um you know as the
uh um company as the company's growing
and you have more and more people
um you know the just the importance of
having
really great communication throughout
the throughout the team and throughout
the company and
um and and you know making sure that
every the
relevant people have all the relevant uh
information in our in
you know and influencing all the
relevant decisions
um it's it's super important and also
um you know not something that just
comes from free out of the out of the
box
yeah yeah for sure um that's one thing
i've learned
and this is a bit of an aside from a
otherwise type of conversation but
um it's important for us engineers to
learn all the soft skills that are that
are required
um to be a leader to be a manager to be
a co-founder of a company
and um those are things that sometimes
we don't
tend to learn when we're diving into
docs and apis and
abstractions and so um finding a mentor
finding some help
um to learn how to be a better
communicator and and a better leader is
something that i
i think there should be a textbook on
right i thought about writing it
you should write it yeah but uh maybe
that'll be a data council project that
we'll do that's a
um unabashedly non-technical thing
because i think a lot of us engineers
um would benefit from that as we want to
continue to grow our careers and
um and really impact the world and and
rally other people behind us as well
yeah well thanks for joining us robert
um
really excited about your journey and
the company um the data council
community wants to support you
however we can so thanks for talking to
us about ray and i'm excited
uh excited to have you here yeah thanks
so much it's been great great chatting
so i just wanted to mention to the
community that
we have other awesome things planned
even though
it's middle of august we're not taking a
summer break
so please join us next uh
in two weeks actually we're going to
have the authors
of apache hootie on the show nisha
and vinoth and they're going to be
talking to us about
apache hoodie and how to essentially
enable transactional capabilities
over your data lakes so that's going to
be a super interesting show that's
in two weeks thursday august 27th
at the same time in the same place so um
thanks again for joining us a reminder
that
we dropped a response form
into the chat window and so if you'd
leave us a little bit of feedback
that would be awesome to know a little
bit about what you thought about the
show what we can do better
what topics you're interested in hearing
in the future is always of interest to
us though
so thanks for joining us everyone and so
long for now